en alberta claudia unos nombres que
entran en la historia del fc barcelona
son las primeras mujeres que residen en
la masía esta academia es desde ahora su
hogar
solo una proporción aún pequeña entre
los hombres pero para laura es una
manera de abrir un camino está avanzando
muy rápido pero sí que hay muchas cosas
aunque que faltan como
la profesionalización en la liga los
sueldos sabemos que no se van a llegar a
igualar pero sí que nos gustaría poder
vivir más cómodamente de él
y bueno para ello estamos luchando la
obra y sus compañeras ven ahora más de
cerca su sueño llegar al primer equipo
hablamos de las mejores de las mejores
el barcelona femenino es el actual
campeón de la liga de campeones de la
liga española y de la copa de la reina
juana fernández hizo parte de esta gesta
y después de recorrer todas las
categorías con el club aplaude que ahora
haya mujeres que puedan integrarse al
completo en el proceso de formación al
vivir en la masía que gracias a todo a
todo el movimiento de este feminista de
la mujer no creo que se ha hecho mucho
ha ayudado mucho no tanto al deporte al
deporte femenino como como en general a
la sociedad no es aquí en la masía en
donde se formaron lionel messi andrés
iniesta o xavi hernández estrellas que
lo ganaron todo para un club que vive
por estos días sus horas más bajas en el
equipo masculino y que en donde las que
más brillan son ellas